[Music]  Kris Jenner says daughter Khloe  Kardashian is a great mom  the best eats he caught up with the 62  year old reality star on the red carpet  at the 2018 Met Gala where she dished on  how Khloe is adjusting to motherhood  nearly a month after giving birth to  daughter true Thompson she's doing great  really really good yeah you saw her at  the game they've decided to be together  is good I've been here so I I'm lost I  know you've come with various of your  children but I think this is the first  time you've come for a date night I  think that will help or you might pay  him a couple years in a row so yeah yeah  what is that it's fun to bring them out  have a little bit really fun yeah yeah  how are the girls I'm gonna wait and see  what they have on that's one of my  favorite things to do is down at the top  of the stairs and watch and walk in  [Music]  [Applause]